Design Thinking is a five-step process
to come up with meaningful ideas that
solve real problems for a particular
group of people the process is taught in
top design and business schools around
the world it has brought many businesses
lots of happy customers and helped
entrepreneurs from all around the world
to solve problems with innovative new
solutions step 1
empathize the purpose of step 1 is to
conduct interviews that give you an idea
about what people really care about
we need to empathize with this situation
for example if you want to help old
people you might find that they want to
keep the ability to walk around in your
conversations they might share with you
different ways they can do that later
into the interview you'll want to dig a
little deeper look for personal stories
or situations where things became
difficult ideally you redo the process
with many people with the same problem
step 2
define the problem looking at the
interviews you can now understand the
actual needs that people are trying to
fulfill with certain activities one way
to do that is to underline the verbs or
activities that the people mentioned
when talking about their problems like
going for a walk meeting old friends
fatigue or simply going grocery shopping
around the corner store you might
realize it's not so much about going out
but more about staying in touch after
your analysis formulate a problem
statement some elderly are afraid to be
lonely they want to stay connected step
3
ID 8 now focus only on the problem
statement and come up with ideas that
solve the problem the point is not to
get a perfect idea but rather to come up
with many ideas like
unique virtual reality experiences
senior friendly hoverboards or a
modified pushcart
whatever it is sketch up your best ideas
and show them to the people you are
trying to help so you can get their
feedback step 4 prototype now take a
moment to reflect on what you have
learned from your conversations about
the different ideas ask yourself how
does your idea fit in the context of
people's actual lives your solution
could be a combination of a new idea and
what is already being used then connect
the dots sketch up your final solution
and go build a real prototype that's
just good enough to be tested step 5
test now test your prototype with actual
users don't defend your idea in case
people don't like it the point is to
learn what works and what didn't so any
feedback is great then go back to
ideation or prototyping and apply your
learning repeat the process until you
have a prototype that works and solves
the real problem now you are ready to
change the world or open shop to
experience Design Thinking first hand do
the free virtual Design Thinking crash
course from Stanford's D school right
now you will learn to design a new gift
giving experience find the link and a
guide for facilitators in the
description below after you are done
share your experience and gift idea in
the comments to learn more about
creative and critical thinking check out
our other sprouts videos and if you want
to support our channel visit patreon.com
slash sprouts
you
[Music]
you